I am gonna buy the New York Jets
and the reason that is going to happen
is really interesting to me see I don't
think I'm really that talented in most
things the only talent that I think
really over index is for me when it
comes to business is truly understanding
that innovation has never cared about
anybody that innovation has put out
businesses the biggest businesses
businesses in between that entrepreneurs
and CEOs and individuals make the
mistake of being either romantic or
naive to what's actually happening
around them and I also understand that
now that the Internet is 20 years old it
is that scale that is actually creating
the speed of innovation that we're
actually living through today I was just
on a call on the way up here with a
organizer of a conference I'm speaking
to on Monday in Miami and it is the
black service limousine conference this
is the owners of the biggest black car
to carry a XYZ the biggest limousine
companies in the world and she's telling
me what they all do and how they fight
with each other and I'm like I bet you
they all rallied together to fight
against uber and she said yep and I sit
there and I think about a company like
uber that is now selling shares of its
stock for 10 billion dollars in the
secondary market that didn't exist 36
months ago and I think about all the
owners of those black harvest services
that didn't care when it launched or
didn't think it was gonna work or all
the arguments that I heard when I
invested in it things like nobody in New
York City will ever use that there's
plenty of taxi cabs we are living
through the gross underestimation of
what's happening see people don't buy an
uber or use an uber because they need
the taxi service they're buying time we
are buying time those extra seven
minutes are worth it for a certain
segment of society and that's why they
do it